ممكن شوارع وهمم اماكن الدوحه تحولت كلها
مناطق للجماهير دعما للمنتخب المغربي هذه
المنطقه همم اذا كانت المدرجات بيعه
التذاكر بالكامل فجميع المناطق التي وهذه
احداها التي تشاهدينها خلفي تم حجزها
بالكامل قبل ثلاثه ايام لا يوجد هناك اي
مكان واي متسع همم
لاي تواجد الجماهير امام الشهادات هناك
امتلاء للساحات العامه نعلم انه في عدد
كبير من الطائرات حضرت من من المغرب وايضا
هناك طائرات حضرت من من الدول الخليج التي
يسمح لها بالدخول بدون بطاقه هيئه شاهدت
اليوم جنسيات مختلفه همم جنسياته اردنيه
وجميع الجنسيات العربيه متواجده اليوم
دعما للمغرب هناك جماهير ذهبت الى
المدرجات وهناك جماهير تدعم المنتخب همم
المغربي في الساحات كما تشاهدين خلفي همم
بالكاد هذه منطقه همم من يعني عشرات
المناطق في الدوحه ممتلئه بالكامل
وهيتابعون مباراه همم المغرب وبالتاكيد
يعني ستكون هناك احتفالات في شوارع الدوحه
في حال همم تاهل المنتخب المغربي الى همم
النهائي ايضا يعني همم كل يوم شاهدت
جماهير مغربيه
تبكي ااه حسره على عدم قدرتها على همم
الحضور في مدرجات الملعب همم قيمه التذاكر
وصلت الى اسعار جنونيه اقبال كبير على
التذاكر ايضا هناك همم سوق سوداء ولو كانت
قليله همم نوعا ما ولكن قد الحدث احيانا
اذا الطلب عالي جدا على الهدف يكون هناك
همم بالطبيعي ان يكون هناك سوق سوداء همم
للتذاكر